for acting classes Terry what what do
you consider being active I know they
always say the actors should continue
yeah well I grew up I grew up in act one
theater which was a school and enough
after-school program and then PTP
professional theater program through
high school every day after school
and where we'd study history of film
we'd do we'd put on different plays
musicals and then when I moved out here
I got connected with Dennis LaBelle he's
an amazing acting coach and I worked
with Jocelyn Jones I always go back to
Dennis because I feel like he's like my
uncle but I I take private lessons from
him and I take his acting class and I
pretty much I try to put up scenes and
work on characters that I don't usually
get booked as so or like things I wish
like dream characters you know or
something but I wish I could do I put
those in class and would a Shakespeare
work hard on monologues just I think as
an actor I know a lot of actors when
they start professionally working
they'll stop practicing in class but you
have so much time off or at least I have
so much time off that I think it's like
any other thing it's not like riding a
bike I think you get rusty it's like
playing an instrument or singing or
playing a sport you have to keep
practicing you have to keep being open
to new characters and working on it
so I'm a huge believer no matter where
you are in your success that you should
always be sharpening that tool what are
the characters that you want to play
that you haven't or that you don't
usually get to like what what are those
roles growing up I always play boys and
I always played comedic parts like old
ladies because I did I did theatre so I
always played really big
comedic characters and in film I always
play kind of like
Ariana's like I more scandalous women
and so in class I like to still visit
comedy and I try to bring comedy out and
other things and then I also my scariest
thing is probably actually super
dramatic and crying and tearing down all
those walls and being like just super
vulnerable so I'm trying really hard to
bring more gentle soft weaker characters
out that I guess you're not weak you're
honestly the bravest if you're okay with
being vulnerable and open in front of
people so for me I think the hardest
characters for me are definitely the
ones that have really gone through
trauma and that are showing all their
wounds it's my least favorite thing to
play so that's why I had to keep working
on it until I loved it I have to be okay
with it
you